o capitão do batalhão de operações
especiais mas com mestrado em
antropologia na universidade federal
fluminense pós graduado em gestão de
pessoas pela g2 de janeiro pela gb
também pós graduado em administração
pública é graduado e pós graduado em
educação física e graduado pela academia
da polícia militar do rio de janeiro
alguns cursos na área policial mas
também alguns cursos que me deram
condição de hoje na aula algumas
universidades libera algumas pesquisas
na área de segurança e foi consultor dos
filmes tropa de elite e tropa de elite 2
que produziu uma discussão interessante
na sociedade brasileira
muito além daquilo que mais uma
expectativa que era relacionado à
questão da violência policial da
violência urbana na questão da corrupção
na sociedade brasileira
mas falando alguma coisa relacionada a
atitudes de pessoas que faz a diferença
parece inspirar outras para que sejam
seguidos por essa é a pessoa que cada um
nessa energia ou sinergia estabelecida
você tem aquilo que nós falamos chamamos
de equipes de alta performance alto
desempenho e que a mídia gosta de tratar
quando fala de forças policiais em tropa
de elite para falar como é que funciona
a vida do policial
alguns integrantes dessas unidades que
atuam no risco máximo dessa profissão
especificamente no rio de janeiro
algumas discussões relacionadas ao bota
mas que não uma polícia muito complicada
estruturalmente moralmente complicada
historicamente do rio de janeiro e que
para não recebeu um centavo a mais
eles submetem a enfrentar o pior risco
que tem na américa latina ou talvez no
mundo na área de segurança pública e é
normal as pessoas diante dessas figuras
como os integrantes do bope é criar em
mitos relacionados a isso algumas
perguntas que me fazem como aconteceu
num estado nas cidades do paraná em
maringá paraná é verdade que vocês
preferem do bope vocês são geneticamente
modificados
é verdade vocês processo do op vocês
retiraram as suas famílias nove anos de
idade levados para campos de treinamento
e as pessoas ficam achando que pra ser
integrante de uma unidade como essa
então sobrenatural não é isso é alguma
coisa diferente
esquece que na verdade nós somos
brasileiros que escolhemos trabalhar uma
atividade chamada segurança pública
integrar uma instituição chamada polícia
militar mas que no exercício dessa
atividade
escolhemos fazer o melhor e por fazer
melhor
essas pessoas acabam integrando se umas
às outras formando uma equipe que acaba
tendo oportunidade junto com essa nossa
força fazer a diferença é trabalho
fazendo história a mais e difícil
liderar uma tropa numa situação de crise
não gente
uma equipe de alta performance é muito
fácil colocar o trabalho na vida
a jornada mas o risco de crédito risco
quando você tem a equipe
o risco é diminuído por por essa força
essa é a grande diferença e eu falo com
muita tranqüilidade que eu sou muito
orgulhoso de ter pertencido àquela
equipe muito orgulhoso de ter tido a
oportunidade de comandar pessoas em se
determinada circunstância que outros não
querer ir por questões naturais pelo
medo pela questão do desafio pela auto
limitação que você se impõe por não ser
capaz de chegar àquele resultado mas eu
tive a oportunidade de trabalhar nessa
unidade
estou muito orgulhoso de ter comandado
aqueles homens porque eles me ajudaram a
ser o que eu sou hoje está perguntando
pra você o capitão e daí o que o capitão
se não uma função dentro da estrutura é
isso que tinha responsabilidade de
determinar aquilo que tinha que ser
feito
o responsável pelo plano de partilhar o
plano de estar junto com a equipe da
execução do plano mas contra um soldado
um cabo e um sargento e um tenente que
está sob seu comando
eles fazem o melhor a gente se empenham
eles se tornam através desse desempenho
o modelo para aquilo que te fortalece
como chefe então através do exemplo
deles você se fortalece e quando isso
teve uma reciprocidade você tem essa
força
toda a equipe de alta performance deve
ter então título nosso na nossa palestra
exatamente o processo de construção
eu sou paulistano conhecido golpe como
caveira 69 não tem sacanagem disse que a
gente está só e simplesmente uma
coincidência é o 69º caveira primeiro
colocado com as operações bp especiais
que eu fiz mas o número foi dado porque
o último colocado que superou seu 68º
caveira então não tem sacanagem vai
rolar a questão de tropa de elite é num
país como o nosso fica muito difícil né
pessoal
a gente vai estabelecendo vai estudando
para tentar entender o fenômeno e como
antropólogo estudou muito em relação a
isso mas o brasil é um país interessante
porque ouvimos muito lemos muito o
brasil não é um país competitivo já viu
isso né
mas se você pegar com a a sociedade
brasileira principalmente no campo
empresarial kuip comparar com outros de
outros mundos no 140 avaliados pelo
fórum econômico mundial que o ranking de
competitividade dos países o brasil está
em 75º lugar não é isso
isso é bom não se você olhar quem está
atrás da gente ser horrível quem está na
frente aí fica procurando os clubes
preocupados mas há uma deficiência ainda
se encontra na área de educação
tanto que um outro programa de avaliação
de alunos ao pisar também estabelece a
questão de avaliação como está o nosso
aluno corpo chegou aos 15 anos de idade
a formação básica dos 74 países
avaliados por esse programa
internacional inclusive aplicado pelo
ministério da educação
o brasil está na posição 76 acima
provocou a oposição a isso interessante
né
em nossa educação formal desde lá o dos
primeiros anos escolares até mais ou
menos mas entrar no ensino médio e no
ensino médio a coisa muda de figura que
tem um negócio chamado vestibular é uma
preparação para você entrar no mercado
de trabalho e comércio as preocupações
que não já começaram lá no início da sua
formação normal e nós em um momento da
nossa formação nós falamos sobre
empreendedorismo e inovação sobre
superar limites liderança
confundimos isso e todos passamos a
nossa
simplesmente ali no padrão mediano
fazendo o suficiente para passar a isso
nossa casa nós temos uma coisa
semelhante qual nossos pais por conta da
necessidade de dedicar ao trabalho se
empenharem reserva um pouco tempo para
estar junto de nós fazendo com que você
reflita sobre a capacidade de fazer
melhor obter melhores resultados não
falamos sobre liderança é uma coisa
muito parece quase utópica pra nós e aí
você tem dois ambientes responsável pela
sua formação que no momento se preparado
para isso
até o momento você vai chegar nessa
necessidade de pensar no seu papel como
cidadão por meio dos estudos o estudante
e posteriormente com você como alguém
que vai exercer uma função colaborativa
qualquer e você vai ser daqui que
descobri isso aí vêm os talentos
individuais
essa é a grande diferença pode falar
preparar esse ambiente vou falar pra
vocês
o papel de operações especiais por conta
desse filme tropa de elite
usamos os princípios do bope exatamente
nessa produção quando fui consultor e
convidado para ser consultor do filme
foi exatamente isso que josé padilha
diretor produtor roteirista ele queria
aplicar os princípios do bope exatamente
nessa produção
o padre me perguntava estouraria os
fundamentos do bota fundamentos do bloco
são três muito básico seleção rio dos
seus integrantes treinamento rígido e
controle rígido de performance conduta
qualidade naquilo que faz e resultado
que você vai obter mas fora é só um
processo você vai ver todas empresas
altamente de uma bola diferente
a questão que a gente tem uma palavra do
chamado rígido porque isto porque no
brasil se você não votar a intensidade
do negócio a coisa não funciona esse
troço é grave mas é a regra é gravíssimo
então o troço parece que tem uma
proporção diferente então o controle
rígido e porque a seleção viaja com o
perfil que eu preciso eu prefiro assim
ele só sabe que no box ao trabalho à
vontade
a história deve ser legal trabalhar no
bota legal trabalhar no golpe porque
desde que vai ser convidado para
trabalhar aqui hoje vamos falar com o
policial que trabalha na rua k eu fui
voluntário porque compreende
um conceito no golpe que era
responsabilidade de um setor da polícia
atuar em determinado campo que a maioria
não quer três meses de um processo de
quatro etapas 500 quinhentos
selecionamos 35 para um programa de
treinamento de 17 semanas
o curso de plano de operações especiais
vocês viam no filme tropa de elite 1 a 1
curso interessante dos 35 selecionado
1.500 depois da primeira semana reduzido
de 8 a 12 para continuar as outras 16
dourado porque você mandar embora não os
caras pedi para sair porque tem de
passar porque não aguenta pressão por
resultado não aguentou a pressão
psicológica e física que você tem que
fazer com que a pessoa passa por ela
para saber se aquele perfil que foi
selecionado está pronto para ser
submetido a uma operação que vai exigir
dela exatamente não normal é anormal
o a mais o extraordinário porque
ordinário todo mundo pode fazer
a moça também não flexibilizou não
flexibiliza a isso a gente só porque a
pessoa vai poder integrar uma equipe de
operações pensar se não for preparada
para aquilo gente compromete toda equipe
pa
então se eu quero vou formar alguém que
vai entrar na equipe eu quero o melhor
melhor seleção melhor treinamento e no
dia a dia o batalhão de operações
especiais o que ele faz a avaliação de
performance individual e coletiva
conduta comportamento prescrito é aquilo
que se previa que fosse feito faça
apropriado para fazer tem que ser feito
o que você previu em termos de de
projeção do perfil é o que você tem que
ver no seu dia a dia
é interessante que às vezes a gente
escolhe a empresa para trabalhar falando
isso porque são nove anos
empresas de todos os segmentos no brasil
inteiro fora do país
as pessoas que estão na empresa existe
algum problema em relação ao valor da
empresa com o seu valor a isso é errado
hamilton que foi prata lapa sofrida por
isso concordei com a questão da polícia
pelo menos aquilo que é instituído a
partir do momento em que aquilo começou
a não considerar com o que eu queria por
fora
então a questão simplesmente atitude
diante daquilo que será levado a essa
questão de resultado
o baseado em cinco pilares que nós
chamamos mandamentos operações especiais
cinco pilares são nossas bases
institucionais primeira delas vão
aprender o saber não ocupa espaço
todo o processo é feito de uma idéia de
aprendizagem o que fez a vale o que fez
com que deu certo melhor que deu errado
corrija usamos para isso o famigerado
perdesse a ferramenta maravilhosa
segundo agir por ter iniciativa não
espero que aconteça faça acontecer no
brasil onde nós vivemos e não é
rotineiramente né
o que nos faltou exemplo pelo menos bons
exemplos maus exemplos são cheios de
pessoas que fazem de vítima diante da
circunstância
vamos ver quem fala não fui eu que fiz
eu assumo a responsabilidade não não
fala e não diz nada
quando o dipolo condicionantes eu não
vou por aí cartoon atitude nisso
então se você aprende se você aja você
também persevera perseverança nossa base
porque dificuldade nós encontraremos
agora superá las
é um dever como ateu e institucional de
compromisso que você assumiu
voluntariamente então perceber a novata
indígena não reclamar daquilo que não
aconteceu
amigo aconteceu de forma diversa não
reclame não de não admitir as
necessárias para você nem aquilo que foi
perdido
não desista da missão essa nossa base
nós somos os nossos principais
adversários são os vidros de nós mesmos
como já foi falado aqui antes
essa é uma grande questão que você está
pronto para vencer e aí vem a história
nós mas a equipe de alta performance
como batalhão de operação especiais nós
não entramos voltava andando pra vencer
então requer um melhor planejamento
melhor preparação melhor execução ea
melhor aprendizagem sempre mostrando que
vocês fazem não se completaram nós
cumprimos missão gente
a missão tem um conceito de valor
agregado a ela você pensa que você
simplesmente com a entrar no mundo
corporativo jantou e você simplesmente
um cumpridor de tarefas não significa
que você não valoriza aquilo que você
tem menos efeito você vai assumir o
compromisso de ver
no bota a palavra nós usamos a missão a
missão nos transforma de meros
trabalhadores algo muito mais relevante
chamado missionário amigo não precisa é
descrito no carro previsto no contrato
de trabalho
um pai uma mãe sabe que a maternidade
paternidade é uma missão que vocês
possam abrir mão de muita coisa por
conta daquilo que vai ser requerido você
no momento você tem custo do cuidado
filho principalmente na dificuldade um
filho ficou doente
passamos a compreender por que nossos
filhos só começa a adoecer não vou dizer
que sou melhor o amanhecer porque
simplesmente aquele momento está sendo
mais exigidos no seu trabalho
isso vai requerer de você uma atitude
diferente abrir mão de conforto que você
precisa de uma estabilidade por conta de
algo tem que ser feito atitude é o agir
e vocês fazem do bope batalhão de
operações especiais temos um lema
vaivéns amigo é aquele que nós queremos
fazer é onde nós queremos chegar é de
cerca de simplesmente confrontar
estratégia e tática deve ser feita para
um resultado que nós chamamos vitória da
icca
como vocês fazem isso é vitoriosa
baseada do pdca tudo definimos como
missão quando a relevância naquilo que
tem que ser feito
sua relevância se você não vê coerência
naquilo mesmo então por que tem que ser
feito se o risco não valer a pena porque
tem que se arriscar a ponte é o seguinte
o seguinte
o propósito dessa tarefa a ser cumprida
se houver relevância porque temos que
fazer então determinei a missão planeja
e sempre para cumprir a missão não só os
casos por ano
há uma chance de acerto plano define
isso planejou prepare-se estrutura
logística daquilo tem que ser feito mas
a minha preparação da equipe cuca
isso nós valorizamos muito gente falar
pra equipe está na frente dela mostrar
que você acredita naquilo tem que ser
feito
a mobilização racional das pessoas se dá
por conta elas entenderem que aquela
mesma forma de fazer mas existe uma
mobilização emocional é quando você dá
sorte dupla sua presença você envolve as
pessoas emocionalmente e aí você tem a
única condição que vai fazer você
consiga superar seus limites e enfrentar
desafios
o indivíduo mas com uma equipe liderança
nesse momento se dá exatamente por conta
dessa capacidade das pessoas
influenciaram umas às outras
mas o comandante faz isso não porque o
comandante diz que tem que ser feito
alguém da equipe vai levantar e vai
assumir responsabilidade daquilo que
você lembrou do tempo em que ela fizesse
é fantástico
então prepare a equipe contra o plano
wilson tempo aqui mas eu acho que não
fica muito bem na plataforma que ocupa a
do plano não vou fazer isto pois
vocês cortas negócio porque seja
disciplinado na execução gente faça o
melhor
esse é um critério nós não dá pra fazer
mais ou menos tem que fazer o melhor
porque você tem um compromisso com toda
a história de todos aqueles que passaram
no batalhão de operação especiais e
ajudar a construir aquela equipe então
compromisso com aqueles que nos
antecederam e com aqueles que viram e
com a sociedade você serve então as
noções impressionante relevante daquilo
que fazemos somos a última linha de
defesa da sociedade
se ela cair ninguém vai poder conseguir
detê assentos que nós quantas pessoas de
bem
a kika e a vale sempre o resultado o
bope erra é a mas temos um critério os
erros são sempre novos nunca eu
repetidos por que por que avaliar o erro
que cometeu
você não vai cometer novamente e aqui
nós chegamos a essa grande conclusão que
existem critérios racionais mais
emocionais que faz com que as pessoas
integrando ao chamado equipe forma essas
instituições como o batalhão de
operações especiais capaz de referenciar
uma ação policial no brasil e não só no
brasil como no mundo que passa a ser um
exemplo
não somos super homem geneticamente
modificado mas temos uma noção de
relacionamento das pessoas entre as
pessoas para chegar ao resultado e o
porquê deve ser feito isso nos define
exatamente como o time poderia voltar a
colocar aqui a imagem do bota foi o voto
aquilo que hoje sim
a força do exemplo é muito importante em
um país como o nosso onde no mundo pelo
menos público que nós estamos convivendo
mas não vemos isso significa que nós
vemos uma crise muito mais sério do que
essa política e social
uma crise moral gente e por conta
exatamente o que a gente não tem
investimento na mão nossas escolas como
os tigres asiáticos fizeram a isso
então vivemos um momento muito sério em
nosso país e nós temos que tomar
exatamente a idéia da verdadeira
dimensão o que nós estamos fazendo para
transformar porque é o nosso exemplo é
que vai fazer com que as instituições se
transforma em carros a esse processo mas
permitiremos que perdura por muito mais
tempo e talvez a gente consiga sair
muito mais nesse ranking que
simplesmente um retrato daquilo que nós
somos tanto na área de competitividade
mas também na nossa área educacional
muito obrigado pela paciência de vocês
gente propriedade